intelligent
infinity
fractaling and finding fractal
find fractal find fractal
find so pumped
to unpack this
we got
a couple cool visuals that i'm going to
go over
and a bunch of awesome
notes as well so
let's jump in intelligent infinity
the source of infinite possibilities
that's you you are
the source of infinite possibilities
you're not
the person you're not the body
you're not your thoughts and your
perceptions and your feelings and your
beliefs and your emotions
you're not the costume
you gain a little bit of subtlety and
you move away from being the person
and you become awareness itself
you become more formless instead of form
bound
then you recognize that awareness
itself is actually impersonal
it's shared and it's eternal and that
it's
endlessly the agent the observer the
witness
that which experiences
all that we create endlessly
as the transient finite creations
and then you gain even more
subtlety
and you turn even awareness
into an object and transcend even
awareness
the first and the last attribute
to the ineffable absolute you
are that source of infinite possibility
that is you
that is your true nature you are that
the nature of that is this
this creation right here right now
appearing happening is that
this is the absolute
we just forget
and play hide and seek we remember
so now you've gained this little
breadcrumb trail
away from the person towards the
subtlety of awareness and towards even
more subtlety of the absolute
you are the source of infinite
possibilities
intelligent infinity is
self-comprehending
its infinitude
okay so i i intelligent
infinity self
comprehending its infinitude
let's say that again i i
intelligent infinity fractaling
and finding just like the heartbeat
lub dub fractal
find lub dub fractal
fine systolic diastolic
fractal find lub dub
that is endlessly
self comprehending
so the two best words
and this is really deeply influenced
by bentino massaro intelligent
and comprehending
intelligent and comprehending
your nature is intelligent infinity
self comprehending its infinitude
yay
and the nature of that intelligent
infinity is satchitananda its existence
consciousness bliss truth consciousness
bliss
causeless joy imperturbable
peace as rupert spyra
taught us a year ago and only really
today
do i feel
that true satyarananda
that's been talked about for millennia
totally causelessly joyful
blissful peaceful
cellular equanimity unshakability
that is your true nature
all right time for the first visual
okay so
this one
has become really exciting because
you see it here
that light getting
prismatically
refracted
into the seven
colors slash
[Music]
or sunday monday tuesday wednesday
thursday friday saturday
which named after
the moon the sun
mercury venus mars
jupiter and saturn
if you dig into the anthropology and the
archaeology
those are the seven celestial bodies
that are visible so thousands of years
ago as we were
figuring out what to do
about structuring the illusion of time
that's what we did seven days of the
week
so now we shall visualize
what you get is
the oroboros
blended together with
light being prismatically refracted
and the
solenoid in though yin and yang
electromagnetic ascension towards an
attractor
all that blended together and we've
talked about this a lot in our first
book high level perception
at highlevelperception.com you can take
a look at it so
let's take a look together and this is
all encompassingly
intelligent infinity
okay
so
what we have here to start is we have
the very clear source
white light refracting
and we'll go ahead and put our handy
dandy
diamond of awareness
okay so
again this is the
first attribute of the
less absolute so the near guna brahmin
the attributeless first attribute saguna
brahman
is awareness it's the agent
the observer the witness you
you me
us
the one shared eternal awareness
now these over here
and again this is all intelligent
infinity
okay
this over here
and i can actually probably write that
here
so this
is also radiating
like the sun
so now let's describe
that ascensionary
density process
so just like the solenoid
just like the electromagnetic flux
between two poles
that ascends towards an attractor
which is the mathematics that a complex
system
evolves towards leveraging things like
automata self-making technologies
like a cell that undergoes a process of
reaching a checkpoint
and then undergoing mitosis to divide
which is how you
turn from a zygote into a 30 trillion
celled human adult
the attractor is at the godhead of this
oroboros
okay so there's our little god head
and now
we illustrate
what are the densities as well
and so we have things
like the
the classical first to seventh
and again when you visualize this as
colors
which it'll be helpful for us to do
our handy dandy
marker box yay
marker box
i feel like that blissful
playful child back in elementary school
back in those youthful years when you
could take the marker box and be like
yay
marker box you can celebrate
this joyfully because that's your true
nature
not some agitated adult wearing a suit
and tie
in the economic machine doing a nine to
five
because you got a 30-year mortgage to
impress people you don't even like with
a house and a car
and a watch wake the [ __ ] up
liberate yourself from maya from the
illusion
from the 3d matrix which we'll talk
about here in the
third density
so we got our handy dandy red
our handy dandy orange
and then we go to the yellow
oh yeah and then some of these smell
this one's banana
soon we'll be able to leverage our
metaverse technologies for you to be
able to even smell this
okay our yellow
when we go to our green this is really
important this represents
the heart this represents love when you
ascend to this level from yellow to
green
is super profound
all right let's do a lighter blue
then we'll do our
cool
now maybe quite
a darker blue this one looks good we can
go with this one
that classic darker blue
yeah cool
and then our violet
all right
so that's really important
then we now have that visualized
yay all right
so
if you check out things like
the law of one go to
law of one dot info
you will find an incredible amount of
metaphysical truth
now the way that they
explain this seven density ascent is
very
very beautiful and
we'll go ahead and go over that briefly
here and then we'll combine that
with some of the other methods
so
a
elevation
an ascension across these densities
as is very much agreed upon in many ways
by even science and evolution
and the analysis of form infinity
where we have
so funny to juxtapose this with
the previous show we did on causeless
joy
it's like both silly playfulness
and we will now
be talking about the seven densities
it's so funny so as
science and the analysis of form has
also concluded
that we spent a tremendous amount of
time in the big bang
and evolution towards the point of
getting a
rock a celestial body that orbits a sun
and somewhere around four and a half
billion years ago
that process of rock ended up
over a span of again another billion or
so
years creating the first
cells cellular organisms which we have a
large hypothesis came from the
geothermal
unlockings from the molten core
of the planet of the rock and then
that slowly over time that that rock
obviously became from single cell to
multi-cell
that then even this cambrian explosion
period several hundred million years ago
and then unlocking us all the way up to
these trees and plants
over the last hundred or so million
years and
even all the way up to dinosaurs that
then
66 million years ago get wiped out
creating
enough of a opening
for these chimps
to become
the dominant species in the last
million or so years evolving
from that plant and animal second
density again so from first
rock to second with plant and animal
and then up we go to
the human so if you look at things
like chromosome 2a
and 2b fusing
in the chimp and if you look at things
like the fox
p2 protein enabling
language and if you look at things like
the stoned ape
hypothesis around us
enabling that accelerated evolution
given
consuming entheogens like magic
mushrooms
that we get to this third density this
human
density now this is very
highly sought after obviously
because you become self-aware
you become aware that you're aware
you become aware that you have choice
that you have
will
that when you're exposed to the choice
of do i serve myself or do i
serve other people which we'll talk
about as
sts service to self versus
sto service to others
you have will you have choice you have
polarity
right so self-awareness and polarity
this is typically what's also called the
third
density or 3d matrix
so when people talk about the matrix
they're
referencing something of course that's
also used in
mathematics but they're talking about it
in a sense of
the government in terms of the economic
machinery in terms of
politicians in terms of propaganda in
terms of all of the main
media companies in terms of all of the
fast food and high fructose corn syrup
and all of the endarkenment and
sleeping mechanisms
that keep people like algorithmic
sheep
rather than liberated
sovereign gnostic
beings that know their true infinite
nature
and that's really what is core here
when you go from the third to the fourth
density
is it's typically the what is called
in many ways the first stage of
enlightenment
which is when you recognize that i am
not
a contracted finite
separate energy egoic
i'm not that and you sort of
relax and expand yourself into a more
cosmic consciousness
you begin recognizing a little bit more
subtly that okay well we all come from
the same
source we all come from that same
big bang and our awareness
then is also shared like our sources
and i become more subtly aware
of awareness itself
and i recognize that the observer the
witness
is paramount it's salient
it's critical
just like i reference in
my dream at night that i have i can't
actually simulate out that dream
and have that experience without
an observer without a witness without
awareness so there is awareness
simulated and the reality
for awareness to experience
so look at your direct experience at
night when you simulate out the dreams
and recognize
the poignancy the paramountness
of the observer of the witness of
awareness itself and then take that here
away from that dream into
your awake state
and recognize that same paramountness
okay so you are
the creator
and you are the awareness
and you are the unique firework
that is your unique gift and expression
that's why the first part is called
nettie nettie not this not that you
negate
being this costume you negate being
even awareness so that you can recognize
yourself as the creator you can
recognize pierce the veilless veil the
gateless gate
to that as your true nature and then
step one
is that neri nettie step two is the
inclusion
so in step two you include yourself as
the creator
as the impersonal eternal
awareness and as the unique
cool firework gift costume
so the ascension from third to fourth
includes that moving away from person
into moving more and more towards
the cosmic consciousness and
it is really critical here
you move away from service to self
dynamics where you want to self deal
to yourself you're trying to extract
peace and happiness
from maya from the illusion from
substances and experiences
and other people to
now you recognize that your nature
is happiness and peace awareness is
nature
is that the creator's nature is that so
you're no longer trying to extract it
from maya rather
you become in service because you
recognize the quote
other is actually the self is the
creator
so that way you become in service to
others or sto
instead of sts
so that's really the core
of where we're at right now
so cosmically speaking
we are
so again this was do re
me we're in the me to fa
and in that me to fa we have to remember
that there's a polarity there there's no
sharp
and so the polarity is the service to
self versus the service to
other and so the
quote 3.5 is where a lot of people are
currently feeling
right now
our role as people that care a lot about
service to others that care a lot about
love
awakening to the fourth density of love
which again
these are the chakras as well
that this fourth chakra is the heart
chakra and when you open the heart
chakra
that's when you get love you get cosmic
consciousness you get the
recognition that we share our being
which is what the definition of love is
so this is so
mission critical when we talk about
things like global enlightenment
or when we talk about the planetary
awakening
we're talking about shifting people from
human third density service to self
to fourth density love service to
others expanding them from
person to more of a
shepherding of consciousness
okay so then
rather than getting into a lot of the
nuances here i'm just gonna
briefly go over these so what happens is
that love
typically becomes overly zealous
and carries too much martyrdom with
it and so what you get is you get a lot
of people that have experienced this
where they go out
with their love and then they go out
with their love to very egoic
levels of service to self-consciousness
and they get
they get slapped
and they recognize after enough
suffering
similarly when you go from third density
to fourth density
suffering is the drill sergeant of
awakening once you
shift from the feather trying to wake
you up to the sledgehammer coming
you awaken similarly with love
when you get the sledgehammer enough
times you
recognize wisdom now wisdom
is when you learn how to gracefully
kindly gently intelligently
say no when you learn how to create
distance
so love can be overly zealous and
martyrdom and wisdom is balancing that
out and saying no i'm not gonna go
overzealously deliver my awakening
to egoic service to self levels of
consciousness
mind body spirit complexes instead
i'm going to wisely distance myself
and create more of a
love and wisdom ascending they go back
and forth
in their ascension until they become one
in the unity state so love and wisdom
go up and merge together into one
the unity state this is also known as
the mirror
state this is a highly advanced
state
and this is when you could say that
you're
extremely pure you
are purely
channeling god's love light
you are purely channeling god's love
light you
have stripped away
your conditioning you've stripped away
your psychology
you've stripped away the quote
unit so the atlas
unit you've stripped that away like
snake skin
shed [ __ ] so now
you see everything as only the creator
you see everything as
only god's love light that love light
awareness interplaying with itself
leela the divine play
so these are very very advanced levels
of consciousness and then when you get
up to this
god state what happens is that you
turn everything over that you've learned
in this creationary ascent
and that's when the do-ray me
fosso la ti
do re me faso
la ti do just like that
so again
just remember that you can also describe
this
as
ego so a lot of
time when you look at somebody's eyes
you can see that the pupil
itself is the shared awareness
right that's why your pupil and my pupil
and all of our pupils are that same
shared
black awareness yet
the iris which is the unique coloration
around the pupil
is unique for all of us which is that
unique
firework that unique gift that unique
individuation
the unique expression of intelligent
infinity
and so in this process of going this
fractaling
what's happening is is that you can
envision the irises
being colored from ego to enlightenment
so again the vast majority of people are
in a state of sort of being
colored as this yellow
around their pupil so they have
yellow irises
some people in many ways are still hyper
egoically service to self
and then you can tell based on the
people you interact with
based on their vibration their frequency
based on their level of consciousness
based on
their causeless joy and imperturbable
peace
based on their sunlight that's radiating
you can tell if god's love light is
purely
emanating that that's when they have
irises colored green
blue indigo violet
etc
so this is the first
critical visualization
and
again there's the refraction
into the octaves of creation
awareness being the first and last
attribute the power to know
a gradiented ascent
from ego to enlightenment
so i'm going to bring up the second
visual here in a moment i want to
share a bit about this
first and last attribute in power to
know
so again awareness is
the first attribute
and awareness
is what observes witnesses experiences
as the power to know
the 10 000 things
so this is the 10 000 things
this is endless finity
endless form endless identity endless
costumes
this is the endless costumes awareness
is what we
share that is eternal the first
attribute
and as we sort of shed
our onion layers of identity and form
what we get to is we get to the same
awareness
that is also the last attribute
so when you're doing neti neti not this
not that
and you shed your onion layers so
the first onion layers you shed are okay
well i'm not
thyme i'm not ego i'm not
separation i'm not affinity i'm not form
i'm not my name
i'm not my ethnicity i'm not my career
i'm none of those things okay so what am
i well i'm this subtle
formless awareness itself
we share our source we share our
awareness
okay and so we all get to the same place
which is awareness so
after you shed all of your attributes
you get to the last
attribute so that's why it's the first
and the last
attribute and once you shed even the
last attribute of awareness itself you
turn
awareness into an object and you
transcend even that
that's when you arrive at this ineffable
absolute
perfect
and that is
this
this is
that you are that
you are the absolute i assure you
you are that
realize that abide
as that
deepen it until it becomes your direct
experience
i am the absolute i am the creator i am
intelligent infinity endlessly
fractaling and finding
i am also the nothingness
shunya the void stillness
and i'm beyond both i'm beyond
everything and
nothing i'm beyond birth and death i'm
beyond
coming and going absolute
timeless free
perfection
so awareness again as that first and
last attribute
and also that
fractaling into 10 000 things
and we can begin
where we share that
that 10 000 things is not
only in the objects in the
perceptions and sensations and emotions
and feelings and beliefs
but it's also the individuals
so you get
the individuals
you get the individuals that
are the result of that fractaling
and then their feel separate
and then that's where you get maya
which is the illusion the intoxication
that you get tempted by
experiences and relationships and
substances
and material i'm going to get a physical
car i'm going to get a physical watch a
physical house a physical boat a
physical plane and then
i'm going to be happy
the classic story
and that's when you get the parable of
the prodigal son
so
in the classic example of the parable of
the prodigal son
and i'm going to go ahead and illustrate
this as well
it will be better
to keep them as two
i can try to merge them into one
let me see
i'm gonna do them as too
all right so
the first and we'll get to the parable
of the prodigal son here
the first fractaling
we will showcase like this
and so that's your
so that's your fractaling
hmm
and so that's where you get the
that's where you get the individuation
the separation the maya
and the parable of the prodigal son so
let's go ahead and
visualize that as well
and then
let's do it right here
so there's your breaking point
right here the parable of the prodigal
son breaking point
and it's an archetype the individual
cannot go further
than that point it's an archetype
it's the furthest a story can be told
it's the furthest a metaphysical
mythological archetypal experience
of the nature of reality can be told
and so you venture all the way out until
suffering
as a separate finite
egoic contracted
individuated energy that's trying to
serve itself
from maya from the illusion gets hit by
the suffering sledgehammer
to the point where it goes i'm done i'm
done trying to extract peace and
happiness from maya i'm done
so enough suffering has happened i'm
done suffering is the greatest teacher
as is nature and so then
the turn inward happens
becoming aware of awareness itself
and that's the second step so that's
that's finding
so you start with the fractaling
and we do the finding
so two
is finding
so you have in many ways the
the fractaling out
so that should visually
make sense fractaling out
like the lub
the systolic the systole and the dub
the diastolic diastole
lub dub lub
what is
really critical
is that
what is meant by finding
is what has been talked about by the
mystics
for thousands of years what does
mysticism mean
it means becoming one
with what with god with what
with the absolute what does yoga mean
it means union union with what with god
with the absolute what does hypnosis
mean of the greeks
the same becoming one with god with the
absolute
again this is so fun the juxtaposition
here
in this video in the previous one the
causeless joy one
in yoga in union
mysticism hinosis
what the sufis meant by wadat al-wujud
is the unity of all finding
meaning that every single one of these
individuated
fractal expressions of intelligent
infinity
has their own unique style
of finding their own unique taste
of finding
so you might taste
a chicken soup as you commune back with
the infinite
and i might taste a beet salad
as i commune back with the infinite
there's endless
tastes of food endless combinations of
food
all 8 billion of us are getting a
unique taste of food
a unique entree if you will
in our union in our recognizing
ourselves as intelligent infinity as the
creator
and that's also very
closely resembled by the different
paths the many paths one end
all of the different faces and
paths to the one end
there are retreats there are books there
are aphorisms there are
entheogens there are all these different
combinations of the different traditions
and whatnot
and all of us will have our own unique
style of finding
okay so that's what's meant by
your unique style or taste
of reuniting and abiding
so you reunite and you abide
you abide as awareness as impersonal
eternal awareness
you abide as the creator you abide as
intelligent infinity
fractaling breaking point
parable of the prodigal son yoga finding
the turn inward what happens
when you recognize your true nature
well then
we go to
number three
so the fractal and find
are the main components but you can add
the third the firework as well
to celebrate uniqueness
to celebrate individuation to celebrate
the gift
to celebrate the unique costume
which is why the west an individuation
is not wrong but that it needs to be
synthesized
with the east and with non-duality
all right so there's our
fireworking
and so then that fireworking
it comes
as wu wei as lautsa said
it comes as effortless action
when you try and self-actualize when you
try
and fire work without knowing your true
nature
guess what happens you treat other
people
like they are different you treat
other people like they are finite
separate egoic self-dealing entities
you don't know your true nature you
don't know them
and you as source you don't know
yourselves as the one infinite creator
so inevitably you're going to catalyze
suffering no matter how awesome of an
entrepreneur you are
you're going to catalyze suffering
because you don't know your true nature
duh that's why 2500 years ago the number
one delphic maxim written on the top of
the temple of apollo at delphi
was know thyself two words know thyself
if you know yourself as intelligent
infinity as the one infinite creator
you know everyone has that and then when
you know everyone asks that
you can literally be in a place
service to others you can unlock the
fourth density
heart chakra because you know your true
nature
you know that serving others is
god's love light
so it becomes that pure service
as god's love light lila you
recognize everything as that divine play
of leelah
and you channel only god's love light
you purify
yourself over and over and over again
as bentino massaro said at the shift
into permanent alignment
retreat in costa rica in march
he became a self-purification engine
constantly calling himself out on all of
his
twists and layers of deception
that's what has to happen in order for
you
and i and all of us that are in this
process
of ascending to the fourth density and
beyond
to really purely become in service to
others
truly you're not trying to gratify
some sort of selfishness in a hidden way
vigilance watching every single one of
your frames every one of your patterns
in behavior
truly knowing yourself to that degree
so you can honestly purify yourself
to that god's love light leela truly
to see everything as the creator and to
see
everything as being
in the purest service
purest service as i said in karma yoga
that you focus on
getting nothing in return
no fruits no attachment at
all you're just selflessly
watering the seeds
not expecting the fruits not expecting
to sit in the shade
and this was also talked about with
bentino massaro and anurag gupta
on the mirror talks podcast
where the prioritization of the roots
focus on your roots focus on where
you're coming from
purify where you're coming from
naturally
if you focus on service to others
and purifying relentlessly vigilantly
where you're coming from purifying your
roots
inevitably naturally
you will experience more
and more of god's love light you will
experience
more and more of intelligent infinity of
the one infinite creator's true nature
true selfless loving
blissful peaceful wise
playful
nature
beautiful
this has been fun and i hope valuable
okay
cool
so again the heartbeat
of intelligent infinity the very
heartbeat as you see
in the title here of the show
is the fractal and the find
the very lub dub just like
our own heart that beats a hundred
thousand times a day
two and a half billion times in around
an 82 or so year lifetime
that the same way that you go lub
with the oxygenated blood and you go dub
with that deoxygenated blood
lub dub
the same way that that cycles in your
alveoli in your lungs
the oxygenated and the deoxygenated
that's why it's called prana that's why
it's called the life
force the breath is that life force
it's here with us all the time it's even
used as the primary
tool in the mystic traditions to unite
yourself with god with the absolute
which we'll talk about in a little bit
but you
use the breath to stop the fluctuations
of your mind
and in doing so you create a pause so
you become the witness the observer you
become more of the awareness and less
of the clouds that appear and disappear
of thoughts and emotions and perceptions
and you become more of the sky of
awareness in which they arise
and dissolve
the very breath and heart
are so deeply interconnected
that's how you move the oxygenated blood
that's how you take
the deoxygenated blood and you cycle
that
back out into the environment which then
becomes further in
the cycle absorbed by phytoplankton and
trees
which then oxygenate it
that you then inhale so you see there's
even
a heartbeat component
on a planetary level
you exist in a
soup
you exist in a soup you are
dependent inter-dependent
as the creator expressing itself
as awareness
experiencing this creation you are doing
so
via a very
interdependent relationship
between your
heart your lungs the planetary
oxygenation with the phytoplankton and
the trees
you can even get
from the third to the fourth
density through an understanding
of physicalism oneness
you can even get to a state of more
cosmic consciousness
through even understanding at a
scientific level
how interdependent we are on the
phytoplankton and trees
see you can even use science
and form and
matter infinity
you can use them to recognize
physicalism oneness and to unlock
that heart chakra in fourth density love
because then you become in love with the
interdependence
you become in love with the
phytoplankton in the trees you become in
love with your 100
000 heartbeats every single day
you become in love with everyone's 100
000 heartbeats every single day
and you become a really good steward you
become a really good
shepherd for the global
awakening for planetary
enlightenment for maximizing human
potential
so there's that very lub dub
the very fractaling and finding of
intelligent infinity
the one infinite creator endlessly
endlessly creatively
anarchically perfectly
freely
and you'll never come to the end
the same way that you'll never come to
the end of all of the different ways
that you can color a blank canvas
or all of the different ways that you
can arrange musical notes into a song
or all of the different ways that you
can arrange images into a movie
or all of the different ways that you
can arrange
food recipes
or all the different ways that you can
vibrate your vocal chords
to make language
and so you can see there's these
different vibrations
for languages
and there's 7 000 of them on the planet
you'll never come to the end of all
of the different ways you can color a
blank canvas you'll never come to the
end of all the different ways you can
arrange musical notes into a song
you'll never come to the end of all the
different ways you can put images into a
movie
all the different ways you can put food
into recipes all the different ways you
can vibrate vocal cords as languages
you'll never even get to the end of all
of the different ways
that you can modulate a screen
take the screen that you're watching
this on right now
watch how it's modulating and guess what
when you switch from
youtube and you switch into
google calendar there's a modulation
when you switch into your text messages
boom there's another modulation you'll
never come to the end of all the
different ways that you can modulate
a screen either
so if you leverage this
understanding of infinity
you will recognize that you'll never
come to the end of all of the ways that
you will
fractal yourself out as
individuals wearing
unique costumes of different form and
different identity
and you'll never come to the end of all
of the beautiful
ways styles
tastes of finding
the way that i tasted my finding
in this creative exploration was
mwah it was so beautiful
so beautiful the most profound
experience of my
life and being compounded
several times more and more satori
deepening ah
and that's what's meant by what the
unity of
all finding all of the unique ways
of finding all the unique styles the
unique
tastes of finding that each of us
are experiencing
and you'll never come to the end of that
fractaling and finding
all of the different ways to make
fractally costumes of identity and form
in all the different ways that they find
themselves as intelligent infinity as
the one infinite creator
all the different styles the different
tastes
of recognizing their true nature
piercing the veilless veil
walking through the gateless gate
popping the bubbleless bubble
as adishankara said 1300 years ago
i am in my village but i need a road to
get to my village
or as rumi said you go from room to room
looking for the diamond that's already
around your neck
you are already the absolute
and yet it remains for you to recognize
to remember that you
are that
and that's the cosmic joke
ah
ah
so remember that remember that
fractal find that lub dub lub
dub
it was really beautiful for me
at bentino massaro's
shift into permanent alignment
retreating costa rica
about three to four now weeks ago
because
what happened is that a lot of
the realization that i'm talking about
right now around intelligent infinity in
the very fractaling and finding
nature came to me
while we were doing a
satsang sadhana we were having
multiple times throughout the day and
especially
in our evening hangouts
we were in our gatherings
abiding
so we would sit both playfully
and jokingly humorously
childlike awe playfulness
satchadanda and yet
at the same time we would go through
these periods
of silence of meditation
of turning inward and the field
that would arise when we were all
tuned inward like that was mwah
super alchemical super catalytic
of abiding in the highest states
and bentino has also refined a really
strong
spiritual music playlist and so i've
also started
undergoing a similar process of curating
some of the best most
conducive music to the alchemical
container to that collective field
igniting
and so on one of the days
in the night when we were doing this
process
there were about a dozen
a little bit more than that people
gathered around a table
at night as we were doing nearly every
night
and that there was the intuitive calling
to
go and lay down on
the ground a little bit away from the
table and away from people
as we all went into that abiding process
with really good
music and what happened was a very
massive
nervous system communion with
intelligent infinity fractaling and
finding
and so i as intelligent infinity
as the one infinite creator directly
experienced myself
undergoing the process of fractaling and
finding
endlessly
all of the infinite possibilities me
being the source
of those infinite possibilities
and tasting all of the different
findings that were happening like at the
speed
of which a hummingbird
flaps its wings happening at that speed
just
tasting all of that finding
as that intelligent infinity fractaling
finding fractaling fighting with them
and of course also feeling all of the
maya and feeling all of the parable of
the prodigal son and feeling
all of the sledgehammers as well
and so this massive just like nervous
system
just felt
so beautiful and divine
and so that's why the idea
of fractaling and finding is
so simple
so explain like i'm five
and so analogous so
beautifully resemblant
of our heart that's why it's the
heartbeat of intelligent infinity just
like it's the heartbeat here
as above so below ultimately
one absolute and relative ultimately one
and then there was a very profound
process of sort of
after that shedding as i
also talked about in this video
shedding snake skin
shedding the identity and the form
shedding the costume shedding what felt
like
much of the final
bits of
the form of the identity of the costume
of this atlas unit
and shedding all of that afterward like
snake skin and then
shooting that off into this black hole
on the oceanic horizon
and there was again one of those massive
nervous system just
[Music]
and that's what happens when god's love
light
becomes really purely pouring
through and that's what was created by
that alchemical container by the whole
team
they enabled that
and that's why they're world class
that's why you should definitely check
out more
of the global enlightenment retreat that
they just posted
the mirror talks podcast that they just
posted
you can go and get access
to the costa rica
shift into permanent alignment retreat i
highly recommend getting access to that
and watching it
you can join the no limits
mentorship in society which are
incredible
the team is world class
and like we mentioned during the episode
there's been a lot of
that purification engine
by them all undergoing that alchemical
process
together frequently right when you have
satsang
and sadhana they speed up
because you're communing and abiding
quite rapidly and reflecting to each
other the purifications
in a very ascensionary way
and that's why many of the retreat
attendees
were very excited about their time
in that ascensionary alchemical
ascension
purification reflecting
god's love light yet also felt
after they left out of the container
that
that the container itself the
satsang and sadhana that's going on that
very disciplined style of
ascending and abiding and al chemistry
and reflecting to each other for
purification is something that
many people at the retreat are
architecting now for themselves
so the shift into permanent alignment to
god's love light away from your
personhood and conditioning
and your ego needing to force its point
of view into everything
the egoic hitchhiker purified out of
the car aligned with god's love light
to the extent at which
you now become a better architect where
you're gravitating towards you
only highest levels of consciousness to
architect with
that's what the shift is you can only
build an architect now with those
that know their true nature at that
level because there's not going to be
that egoic hitchhiker that needs to
force its point of view
this righteous point of view
that creates holes
in the ship
and i also got that reflected to me it
was one of the most important parts
of my experience at the retreat
was getting reflected to me
that there is still purification that
needs to be
done so that the atlas unit slash
costume slash form slash identity slash
ego
does not need to force its point of view
in some sort of a needing or a lacking
way
to create a hole in the ship
and that's why they're creating a very
navy seals
style boot camp of purification
to ensure that in this macro level
vision of igniting the global awakening
that there's no holes made in the ship
and again the more that you undergo the
process
here of refining your service to others
purifying your service to others
ascending towards these higher densities
the more you
channel purely god's love light
purely you see everything as god's love
light and there's
never coming from a place of lack or
need but it's only coming from a place
of love and light of radiating sunlight
karma yoga no expectations of fruits
just in pure service playfully
blissfully joyfully peacefully
if that resonates with you the lub dub
fractal find of intelligent infinity
leverage
that as something that you
tune into as a direct experience
of your true nature
because bentino and the team
and many of these highest level
spiritual mystics have made it clear
that it's not about taking
what resonates and then going and
seeking more that resonates and seeking
more that resonates and seeking more
that resonates and consuming and
consuming and consuming
but rather take the one
just like the calling that single-minded
focus
in this case for me really abiding
as intelligent infinity fractaling and
finding
abiding as the one infinite creator
abiding as the impersonal
eternal great i am
awareness
abiding as this is that
that is this these
core concepts are like the calling
you want to very single-mindedly hone in
on what really resonates with you and
not just oh
move on to the next thing hone in
so if this resonates hone in lub
dub fractal find lub dub fractal find
cool all right beyond
endless transients and beyond nothing
happening absolutely
timelessly free ineffable
perfection
when you look the classic phrase of
nisargata maharaja
love says i am everything wisdom says i
am nothing and my life flows between the
two
so love is
the endless transients lila this play
this is the absolute everythingness the
all that is-ness the great i
am-ness witnessing all of this endlessly
and then you have this very voidness
this very nothingness this very
shunya this very stillness
this very near guna brahmin
attributeless
agentless nothing happening
you are beyond nothing happening
and you are beyond everything happening
you're beyond endless transience
and you're beyond nothing happening
you are absolutely
timelessly free
ineffable perfection
and i highly recommend reading again the
law of one
law of one dot info you can also watch
the video on our channel
about the law of one in the seven
densities we'll be making more content
about the law of one soon
and you can also watch bentino's videos
on the law of one as well
and one of the core aspects that was
also
mentioned in the law of one is that
we've been refining our creativity as
intelligent infinity
as in we've underwent a process of
vehicular
improvement so when you think about this
creatively this
mind-body spirit complex that are these
individuated fractals
that those have been refined over time
this vehicle
has been refined over time to be what it
is in this creative expression
and the reason why is because as you see
here in this next part that the
wandering
outward the turning inward finding
itself
endlessly in the process of knowing
yourself accepting yourself and becoming
the creator
that entire process and even
the process of the quiet
the process of learning yoga's chitta
vritti
nirodha as told by patanjali two
thousand years ago
that union yoga is simply
the cessation of the fluctuations
of mind use the breath
[Laughter]
recognize yourself as the sky that
watches the thoughts
and the perceptions and sensations and
emotions and beliefs arise and disappear
and when you create that pause and that
juxtaposition you stop the fluctuations
of the mind
and you recognize yourself as the subtle
formless awareness itself
as the i am
and you recognize that that is shared
and eternal
and you recognize yourself as that which
creates
awareness and that which creates
realities
and that enables the union with the
absolute which you already
are yet it remains for you to recognize
it
and so
the
vehicle itself is refined
to a point this entire creation is
refined to a point
where there's maximum
alchemistry happening there's maximum
learning there's maximum lila maximum
play
maximal lessons happening so the vehicle
of the fractally separation has been
maximized and refined
so that when you get to the stage of
this third density
yellowness of the sts service to self
versus sto service to other
that it becomes this really alchemical
playground that is highly sought after
by those that want to incarnate for the
most
intense mind-blowing playful
experience this
is the absolute this is
the coolest most fun game
possible in town
we've literally created a veiling
mechanism for ourselves to forget
to hide and then seek and remember
a veilless veil a gateless gate
one infinite one intelligent infinity
able to veillessly veil itself
to undergo the process of amnesia
and then in amnesia forgetting and
remembering
lub dub fractal find fractal find
fractal fine
and so we've refined this entire
creation and we've also refined the
vehicle this mind body spirit complex
itself
it's a super profound point for those
that
understand it for those that recognize
the profundity of it
and so simply relax into your natural
state
take the time
to relax
use the breath
to relax back into
awareness itself
pure bear empty awareness
the very fact i am i exist
before any description before any
symbolization
just the perfection of
timeless being itself
the presence energy
and as you relax into that natural state
of yours
you will over time do these gym
repetitions
where you become more and more subtly
aware
of yourself as that impersonal eternal
sky of i am awareness
and you'll be less and less
distorted and distracted and attracted
into the clouds of thoughts and emotions
and feelings and perceptions and beliefs
and
maya the intoxication of form and
identity
and ego and separation and seeking peace
and happiness externally
and so these are gym repetitions relax
back into that natural state of the i
am awareness the impersonal and eternal
and then recognize that the natural
state that is right there
that is that is existence consciousness
bliss that is peace consciousness bliss
truth consciousness bliss imperturbable
equanimity causeless joy
that is the natural state and then you
bring
that peace and happiness as the
radiating sun of god's love light
with you in the tantric tradition you
weave
your enlightened realizations into the
social fabric
and that's how you maximize human
potential
you maximize your own
knowing yourself
and then you radiate out like god's love
light as the sun
selflessly the sun never asking for
anything in return endlessly radiating
love light
and you radiate out to your family your
friends co-workers
community people online the world
and that's how we awaken it as a planet
that's how we enlighten as a planet
through consciousness through elevating
consciousness away from personhood
towards
shepherding towards stewarding
planetary awakening
and you can even turn that impersonal i
am that's eternal into an object
rather than a formless subject and you
can transcend
even that very last attribute of the
agent
itself to what is completely
attributeless and agentless
the absolute and you can practice that
process
this is your natural state is to
recognize yourself as intelligent
infinity
as the one infinite creator
and then include awareness and then
include
your unique costume your unique firework
your unique gift
that you're bringing but you're doing it
from a place of
pure god's love light pure
intelligent infinity service to others
and that's a nice little meditation into
relaxing into our natural state
similarly to how a flower blossoms
towards the sun or
similarly to how a
caterpillar undergoes metamorphosis and
becomes a butterfly
it's effortless
it's effortless
recognize that you are the same
you are the flower
that is blossoming to the sun you are
the caterpillar undergoing metamorphosis
into the butterfly you are that
let go surrender
become more like the planetary
hydrological cycle just effortlessly
flowing
relax into intelligent infinity relax
into the truth
relax into the faith and conviction
that you're aligned
to calling to the absolute highest
service to others purely as god's love
light is going to naturally
unfold just like the flower
blossoms to the sun and this is exactly
why
johan wolfgang von guerte has one of my
favorite quotes
which is that
light becoming prismatically
refracted
into the visible light spectrum
and metamorphosis
of the caterpillar becoming the
butterfly those two things
are proof that the ultimate
educational lecture lies in the
artists sphere of work
this phenomenon and the phenomenon of
metamorphosis
are proof that the ultimate educational
lecture
lies in the artist's sphere of work
which is exactly why
i have that obsessive calling
around distilling our true nature into
art that's what i did with high level
perception
and that's what i'm going to continue
doing because it's
so fun it's my child bliss
expressing itself it's the unique
fireworking
but refining that from a place of pure
love light
of pure service rather than needing to
fulfill some sort of egoic
kink of needing to prove that this atlas
unit knows something you see the
difference it's very subtle
it's very subtle
so intelligent infinity wants you
intelligent infinity has the gps call
back
this is the dub and
i love that term by bentino sorrow gps
callback it's such a good way to put it
that is that
fractaling the lub the dub the finding
the finding itself
is the gps callback lub dub
lub dub there's this gps callback
and then it fireworks from purity
and this is why desire for
creator realization and purification are
in that
north star position of the highest
desire
the more that you intensify
your desire the more you remove all the
obstacles
people don't want it bad enough that's
why nissar got to maharaja and
sadhara obsessively compulsively talked
about earnestness
earnestness is key you have to [ __ ]
want it
hardcore how bad do you want to create
or realize how bad do you want to know
your true nature
how bad do you want to pierce the
veilless veil
get through that gateless gate
how badly do you want to purify your
intention of where you're coming from so
that you can be
of the highest service as god's love
light
rather than be fulfilling some sort of
egoic
kink distortion
how badly do you want to
solely bring pure sun
radiance with you everywhere
and so what is in that desired position
and how bad do you want it how much
earnestness do you have towards it
the more that i intensified my desire
for knowing my true nature in the last
five years how it
increased like a power law in terms of
how much i was desiring it in the year
2020
the reason why i broke through was
because
in 2020 i did nothing but
desire my true nature nothing but that
nothing but that it's the only thing i
did
but most people don't want to dedicate
80 hours a week
to knowing their true nature but guess
what happens when you [ __ ] do
you break through fast as [ __ ]
intensify your north star desire
and watch the obstacles dissolve watch
your earnestness
increase and watch you pierce the
veilless veil
faster and as you do so
you become a much better
expression of intelligent infinity in
this
collective shared creationary dreamed
exploration
don't you wanna know your true nature
don't you wanna know your true nature
don't you wanna know yourself as the
creator
don't you want to know your true nature
so you're on an endless river
and the river is an illusion
you're [ __ ] hilarious
intelligent infinity is so funny
you're on this endless river
of becoming ascending in all of these
dreamed creations and yet
this endless river itself is an illusion
and you're complete nothingness voidness
shunya stillness as your everything
all that is all possibilities
infinite possibilities the source of
that
the endless fractaling and finding
and yet the immovability
behind that
you're hilarious
you're the cosmic joke it's gorgeous
the beyond everything and nothing
the beyond all coming and going beyond
all birth and death
just the absolute
timelessly free and perfect
and these are great quotes from bentino
from the retreat
the infinite mystery getting to know
slash play with itself
if it can open and close it's not
the heart
manus molte core unum
many hands one heart
intelligent infinity is that
one heart the one infinite creator
to one heart
endless form endless creativity endless
appearances
endless costumes one heart
one heart
one heart
one heart one heart
one heart just one heart
so simple
ah great
so
we'll wrap
so again intelligent infinity the source
of infinite possibilities
infinite self-comprehension
of the infinite intelligent and
comprehensive
refracting
into this octave
of creation awareness being that first
and the last attribute this very
solenoidal polarity electromagnetic
ascension towards this attractor
for the complex system the godhead
this being so critical
unlocking that heart chakra
from yellow to green service to others
in the lub dub lub dub
fractal find firework fractal find
firework fract fractal find firework
fractal find firework
fractal parabolic prodigal son breaking
point
finding yoga union
firework effortlessly purely as god's
love light expressing yourself
as the unique gift the unique
firework
all the different possibilities all the
different tastes
styles of union waddata jude
and that's it
listen back in on that meditation around
relaxing into your natural state
listen back in on
the unpacking of intelligent infinity
both here and here
go and read the law of one
and find the link in the bio below to
that
and find also the video on our channel
where we break it down
the seven densities
and bentino has great videos on that as
well
i'm so grateful for that alchemical
container
and how it enabled this
fractal find realization of
intelligent infinity
and just recognizing that that is
what we are talking about we want to
create
more alchemical containers for
the ascension from the third density
towards that fourth density of love of
cosmic consciousness
to service to others
so let's hone in on that
as we hone in on the global awakening
planetary enlightenment
the video brought you value
i would love for you to like the video
it helps the youtube algorithm
if you haven't yet subscribe to the
channel
and share the video with people that you
feel like this would resonate with
so that more people can remember
recognize
themselves as intelligent infinity as
the one infinite creator
it's mission critical it's paramount
elevating consciousness
is our ticket to creating the largest
butterfly effect
on this collective creation
and i'd love to hear how you feel about
this show
on intelligent infinity and the fractal
and finding
let me know how you feel in the comments
below love to hear from you
the community is strong here
with simulation adore you infinitely
thank you thanks for being here
i highly recommend checking out mirror
talks podcast by bentino massaro as well
super strong great job by them and the
team
super great corey played a massive role
in that corey katuna
also onorag lupta played a big role in
that kelly
broderick as well and the production
team and whatnot
and read the law of one it'll really
help it'll help a lot
law of one dot info the links in the bio
below give that a read it'll help a lot
i control
and surrender to
the flow of
love that will heal me
i release control
and surrender to
the flow of
love that will heal me
it's been a favorite song of mine
recently
i release control
and surrender to
the flow of
love that will heal me
i release control
and surrender to
the flow of
love that will heal me
fractal fine fractal fine lub
dub lub dub
thank you
you